this is beauty week and we're gonna kick
off the latest eye shadows sprouting up
everywhere beauty crew reports that
green
is the new color on everyone's lids
here's issa rae
lucy hale and zendaya rocking
emerald eyes now zanna for people who
want to go green
give us some tips some pro tips on how
to approach it
whether you're going to go minimalist or
maximalist i think minimalist is the way
forward this a little goes an awfully
long way
i love the idea of just a liner right
and so even instead of a black eyeliner
choose a green i love these ones we have
here we have a plethora of green in
front of us
so this flower beauty great green
eyeliner you can pop it on the top lid
just in the water line maybe alone not
even on the top one is a really good
look
kick it out to the side a graphic
floating eye if you want you don't have
to do a full on shadow
and also it's good rule of thumb when
you're picking which green you want to
wear as well
wow if you have like a cool skin tone
it's good to wear
one of the cooler greens which would be
apple colored lime colored
mint colored if you have a warmer skin
tone
these ones are great like the olives
they're more foresty greens
i love that you say cool skin color for
just plain pale
right i mean i'm a white walker here in
the city with with no sun
what is this santa just easy
easy on the go color chalk so just one
swipe you're on the go
it saves on the tools the brushes it's
just a very easy one pop it in the
plastic there
this is very comfortable cute okay i'm
in love
all right zanna your story next okay so
next there's a brand new serum and it's
not for your face
but it's for your arms birdy reports you
beauty's
sculpt arm compound claims to not only
tighten and refresh your skin
but also contour your arms same white
yes it'll basically make you look fit
can i have some of it oh my gosh so it
consists of probiotics retinol
antioxidants and glutathione so but the
main ingredient is this marine extract
which is the key ingredient that
recreates the signal sent to your
muscles
during a workout so it basically makes
them tighten and contract to look more
defined look at this thing look at this
face
guys do you think you're ready for some
super space age arm serum
yeah give it hit me um is there like a
vat i could see
myself like could i just be dip
the whole body in and then out well
because
when you've lost a little weight or you
go up and down like i do
right your skin really pays a price so
this could really tone it me up
it could really tone you up it basically
contains these
give me give me so it's gonna like a
serum it acts and tightens and tauts the
skin so you basically can see the muscle
definition a bit more
um it smells amazing it feels amazing
we're gonna fight over this one drew
guess what rossi we're gonna both get to
the bed
all right i'm obsessed this is fun who
knew i'd have this much fun on beauty
week as a natural beauty
all right next it's time to dig into the
tick tock bucket
shave reports of the latest skincare
scrubber all over tik tok
is the hashtag exfoliating glove people
say these rough gloves if used two to
three times a week in the shower
will leave you feeling soft as the day
you were born
drew because apparently we're all loaded
with a bunch of
dead skin cells just waiting to be
scraped off uh which is kind of gross to
think about but it makes sense
i'm doing it on my arm and i'm seeing
like dead skin fly off
i'm not kidding uh-huh i really am okay
so here's what i'm gonna do
what i'm gonna do this first get out of
the shower
towel off and then use that serum oh my
gosh
because by taking that dead skin off you
are making your skin
so much more prime and ready to reap all
the benefits of anything you pop on it
moisturizers serums etc you're so right
drew
all right zanna it's your story okay
next we've got some beauty green news
more green news
pop sugar reports more beauty brands are
making use of food waste to create
up-cycle
products it's a huge trend products have
been repurposed for ground from ground
coffees discarded apricot stones
leftover arrogant shells and they're key
ingredients now in skincare
and these foods have amazing benefits
for example
coffee's been shown to brighten the skin
and help reduce
inflammation that's right i'd love to
see
all these natural ingredients not going
to waste well
for me this feels like skin composting
yes
right can we just climb that right here
right
done i'm so into this i think what i
want to do is like
compost stuff for the skin and then get
a mortar and pestle
and like make my own concoction or i
could just go to whole foods and buy
some
oh you know where you could go so
apparently the body shop are taking
they're calling it the wonky banana
collection the wonky banana that was my
frat name
oh sorry i'm gonna put that nickname and
i'm gonna make just
change yours just comes out i'm sorry i
love it
so the body shop are basically taking
buying up all
the wonky bananas that look bad but i
still have packed
with nutrients and then putting them
into skincare ingredients
and with carrots as well oh that's great
i
love this i love that it's skin
composting i it's
that's the new hashtag drew you did it
hashtag skin composting
i'm so into this and finally we are
celebrating beauty week all week long
but we cannot let a beauty pro
go like my sister in beauty xana without
an
expert pick zanna i want you to share
one product that you're obsessed with
right now i'm certainly hoping it's from
the milk makeup line
well funnily enough it absolutely is
okay so this is sunshine skin tint
and it's a three in one i'm obsessed
with it because it's the multi-tasking
mess-free makeup that i personally am
obsessed with right now
so it's a three in one it's basically a
skin tint
it's got hydrating oils and it's also
got an spf 30 in it
so very simply you can pump okay this
packaging
salmon you get the six little balls here
which is enough for one dosage of one
face
so you don't have to put too much or too
little on your face pump
roll blend super easily to blend
and then go oh zanna
this is brilliant i have to talk also
about the coverage
holy cow this coverage is incredible
dewy
uh well pigmented absolutely covering
everything on my hand look at this my
hand went from like
scaly and veiny and discolored but
it's got a really nice dewy finish that
doesn't also move around everywhere
no slip congratulations this really is a
star product
coming from you who knows so much about
packaging the industry and how much it
takes to pull together a great product
from component to formulation
that means the world the formulation as
well as the packaging is impeccable
[Music]